bonsoir en éclats merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france déjà première
question vous êtes au royaume uni est ce
que c'est un procès qui est
particulièrement suivi sur place qui
fait couler beaucoup d'encre qui est
attendu par les britanniques
bonsoir bonsoir je ne dirais pas qu'il
s'agit d'une formation majeure mais ce
ne sera peut-être demain aujourd'hui
beaucoup de journées on nous parlait ce
n'était pas le grand titre en fait cela
a été éclipsé par ce qui s'est passé par
exemple avec la ferrari tonnes larry
dunn était un jeune britannique de 19
ans qui a été tué sur sa motocyclette en
octobre ils étaient tués par une femme
américaine à proximité d'une base
aérienne
cette dame est retourné aux états unis
et les états unis ont refusé de
l'extrader
afin qu' à quelques ajustements au
procès on prétend qu'elle conduisait du
mauvais côté de la route
son mari travaillait pour la cia et ils
ont utilisé leur immunité diplomatique
alors même qu'il ne faisait pas qu'ils
ne figuraient pas sur la liste des
diplomates
beaucoup de britanniques disais pourquoi
d'extradition de julian assange
c'est un citoyen australien n'oubliant
pas il n'est pas américain
pourquoi devrions-nous l'extrader vers
les 16 minutes alors que les états unis
refusent d'extrader leurs citoyens cette
femme qui est lié à la mort d'un
d'une jeune britannique parce qu'elle
conduisait le présume qu'ils ont écouté
de la route
et pourtant les etats-unis ont refusé de
l'extrader
donc les personnes pensent que les
etats-unis se croit capable de pouvoir
exiger que tout le monde le souhaite
extrader vers eux-mêmes des relents
détection même s'il ne s'agit pas
l'américain donc pour beaucoup de
britanniques
c'est un sujet de réflexion n'empêche
oui bien plus même s'il aurait fait
auparavant et certains disques durs
julian assange devrait pas être extradé
avant la fin de la sphère de ce jeune
homme
alors il n'empêche ce parallèle est
peut-être intéressant mais enfin un
procès sur les droits c'est sur les
faits chaque histoire évidemment est
différente
est ce que le risque que ton monde
craint évidemment c'est ce que ce procès
selon vous sera forcément politique où
les juges britanniques assez réputés
sains d'ailleurs pour leurs compétences
vont être finalement assez serein assez
indépendant est assez forts dans leur
tête pour éviter de tomber dans ce
travers
on imagine que les pressions sont
forcément très forte sur eux la pression
est très forte comment le savons nous
commençons maintenant que c'est
politique c'est très simple il suffit
d'examiner les emails qui à mon goût du
camp futé des emails des autorités
britanniques aux autorités suédoises
julian assange a été accusé d'agression
sexuelle
ensuite parce que le procureur
britannique a envoyé un mail disant ne
nous est pas ne le prenez pas peur à 118
s'agissant d'attaqué jeunes un singe en
suède
pourquoi les autorités britanniques
s'intéresserait pen n'a aucun cas
suédois
l'australien qui m'ont fait face à des
accusations de crimes sexuels et de
julien assange avait travaillé dans
d'autres domaines que les btp par
exemple elle ne pourrait imaginer que
les britanniques s'y intéressent mais
ils ont envoyé ces opérations de pour
tous et la suède a attaqué julien
assange et à mener le procès donc cela
montre qu'il s'agit d'une affaire
politique et qu'il ya beaucoup de
pression sur les juges et sur le milieu
judiciaire système judiciaire l'exercice
n'exerce pas dans le vide
c'est un cas très typique julien sage
montre exposé ce qui se passe dans les
coulisses il a dévoilé des crimes de
guerre les perpétrateurs de ce crime et
ceux qui ont essayé de les ouvrir à
s'assurer qu'il ne sera jamais le verrez
donc effectivement il ya d'énormes
pressions sur les juges et le milieu
judiciaire
il faut que les extras de julien san
jose états unis les états unis
aujourd'hui qui accuse julian assange
d'avoir mis en danger à des sources en
révélant plusieurs informations
qu'est ce que répondent les défenseurs
justement du fondateur de wikileaks à
ces accusations
ils ont demandé plus de détails il ils
ont eu raison
aujourd'hui c'est le premier jour de
l'audience d'extradition l'avocat
commence déjà à très fort il explique
qu'il ne s'agit pas de wikileaks de la
fuite de ces documents sur la crim sur
la guerre d'irak ou d'afghanistan
le problème c'est qu'il ait mis la vie
de ces gens en danger mais ils n'ont pas
sans donner de noms les avocats de
julien sage qui nous avons besoin de
plus de détails comment pouvez vous
affirmer cela sans le prouver
vite été mise en risque
dites nous la vérité car tout ce qu'il a
fait tout ce que wikileaks à faire c'est
publié des documents qui sont vrais et
n'ont rien inventé ils n'ont pas menti
ils sont publiés des dossiers des câbles
symptomatique des câbles diplomatiques
des vidéos de ce qui s'est vraiment
passé donc s'agissant de qui met la vie
de qui est en danger il est relativement
clair que les guerres qui ont été
déclarés et ensuite révélés par
wikileaks était absurde à l'époque et
aujourd'hui nous vous voyons la personne
qui a montré de quoi laisser crimes de
guerre accusés devant les tribunaux et
non pas les personnes qui ont causé ces
guerres lors de la guerre d'irak
un million de personnes sont mortes et
pourtant c'est l'invasion d'irak étaient
illégales en matière de droit
international
les personnes qui ont prévenu cette
guerre et qu'ils ont données ne sont pas
accusés
c'est la personne qui a révélé ces
crimes de guerre qui est accusé donc ce
sont les les personnes qui poursuivre
julian assange qui met sa vie en danger
une dernière question une claque
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est exact de
dire finalement que de condamner je
viens assange à l'extradition aux
etats-unis ces deux clairement le
condamné à la prison à vie
oui je pense que c'est tout à fait le
cas il pourrait effectivement être
condamné le théoriquement à 175 années
de prison il ne veut pas en sortir en
vie c'est évident le problème c'est que
s'il était libéré
alors oui qu'ils continueraient mais il
continuerait
publié à exposer des crimes si on ne
viennent pas des guerres c'est légal
alors on a une raison de s'inquiéter de
lucky luke
sa seule chance s'il est extradé aux
états unis serait peut-être de promettre
qu'il arrêterait son travail pour les
kilic c'est qu'il ne s'occuperait plus
de politique et qu'il retournerait en
australie avec sa famille qu'il
arrêterait ses actions les mic
cela serait peut-être le seul moyen de
garantir sa libération s'il était
extradé
il resterait le problème du point de vue
des etats-unis il va il à faire un
exemple de ce carry car s'il se montre
clément envers julien assange alors cela
serait-il assez dissuasif pour les
personnes qui veulent suivre son exemple
la chance une libération est très basse
et dépens de julien assange serait prêt
à trouver un accord et je pense que s'il
était extradé il ne quitterait pas la
prison à vie
remercie beaucoup déclarent que d'avoir
été avec nous journalistes indépendants
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir merci à
vous